Latin America is facing challenges
poverty it's a big contrast between the
rich and the poor education is always
very low women have less opportunities
than men and we are half the working
horse but I think one of the main keys
to the success is integrating the
differences and one of the differences
that I see an opportunity for love
America is in the environment we are
extremely rich and now with a climate
change I think we are all perceiving
that it is very necessary for us to look
at the environment as a value to be
protected and I planet depends on our
awareness and our attitudes must change
my behavior has changed we should see
less consumerism and will have ways to
be happy like index of happiness as
other countries are doing maybe it's a
way for us to find opportunities to
develop in another way exploring less
nature and exploiting less than people I
think it's a celebration of life and
education that is different the patient
be implemented in our countries and I
believe it's possible so it's a question
of daring new paths and I think we can
get there